ACTIVE CHUTER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FOR SURE.
DANA LOESCHE GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT SO CALLED GUN VIOLENCE AND
WE ARE AS WE SHOULD BE,
THOUSANDS ARE SHOT TO DEATH
EVERY YEAR MOSTLY IN OUR CITIES.
IF THAT BOTHERED YOU SAID, THOSE
ARE YOUR CONSTITUENTS OR YOU'RE
A DECENT PERSON WHO CARED ABOUT
HUMAN LIFE, THEN YOU WOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
WHERE IT WAS OCCURRING.
BUT THEY'RE DOING THE OPPOSITE.
THEY'RE LETTING GUN CRIMINALS
OFF IN CITY AFTER CITY ACROSS
AMERICA.
BUCK SEXTON HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS SHOCKING TREND, HOST OF THE
CLAY TOMORROWS AND BUCK SEXTON
SHOW HAPPY TO HAVE HIM.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
HOW CAN YOU SCREAM ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE AND THEN AS A MATTER OF
POLICY LET GUN CRIMINALS GO?
>> THIS ALL STRETCHES BACK YEARS
NOW TO THE END MASS
INCARCERATION TALKING POINTS
THAT PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS
WHETHER KRASNER, GAS CONE KIM
FOX, PHILADELPHIA, NEW YORK
CITY, LOOK AT THE PROSECUTORS IN
ALL THESE PLACES, THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT ENDING MASS
INCARCERATION THAT MEANT BRING
DOWN THE NUMBER NUMBER OF PEOPLE
OVERALL IRRESPECTIVE OF ANYTHING
OUT IN THEIR COUNTY AND CITY
PRISONS AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN ON
THE GUN FRONTS SPECIFICALLY IS A
LOT OF DIVERSION PROGRAM A LOT
OF DROPPING OF THE CHARGES.
IN THE CASE OF PHILADELPHIA YOU
HAD MORE THAN HALF LAST YEAR,
AND THIS IS ON THE PHILADELPHIA
DA WEB SITE YOU CAN GO CHECK IT
OUT.
MORE THAN HALF OF PROHIBITED
POSSESSERS, PEOPLE PREVIOUSLY
CRIMINALS OR NOT ALLOWED TO EVEN
HAVE A FIREARM, THEY HAD THEIR
CASES DISMISSED ENTIRELY.
SO THESE ARE OFTEN PEOPLE THAT
HAVE ALREADY HAD A CRIMINAL
RECORD THAT ARE UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES ABLE TO CARRY A
GUN, THEY'RE CARRYING A GUN
ILLEGALLY AND THEY JUST MAKE THE
CHARGE GO AWAY.
SAME THING IN NEW YORK CITY.
OUR FRIEND JOE BORELLI OF STATEN
ISLAND HAD A GREAT PIECE IN THE
POST LOOKING AT ABOUT HOW ABOUT
4500 GUN ARRESTS IN NEW YORK
CITY, ABOUT A THOUSAND,
SOMETHING LIKE 900 AND CHANGE
EFFECTIVELY WERE MADE TO GO
AWAY.
AND THEY'RE EITHER GOING FOR A
LESSER SENTENCES, PLEA BEAR
BEGANS FOR LOWER CHARGES SAYING
IT'S A MINOR DRUG CHARGE.
ACTUALLY YOU DECIDED NOT TO
CHARGE THE GUN CRIME.
THEY'RE DOING THIS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
SEEM TO BE COMING DOWN TOO HARD
DISPROPORTIONATELY WHERE THERE'S
ALREADY UNFORTUNATELY FAR TOO
MUCH GUN VIOLENCE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, BUT LETTING
VIOLENT PEOPLE WITH FIREARMS
WEAK DOESN'T HELP THE POPULATION
OF CITIES.
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY CARRYING THE
BRUNT.
>> AMAZING WHEN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT MAGAZINE RESTRICTIONS AND
GUN SHOW LOOPHOLES WE ALL KNOW
MOST IS COMING FROM HANDGUNS
RELATED TO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
A LOT IS GANG VIOLENCE AND
CENTERED MAJORLY IN CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT YOU THINK YOU WOULD
HANDLE MORE THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT
THROUGH THE JUDICIAL PROCESS
THROUGH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS.
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN NEW YORK IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE AND PEOPLE
HAVE KIND OF WOKEN UP TO THIS
TUCKER, THEY HAVE MADE IT SO
HARD AND ONEROUS TO FROM LOWER
LEVEL GUN CRIMES MEANING
POSSESSION, LOWER LEVEL CRIMES
ACROSS THE BOARDS INTENTIONALLY
THAT THEY HAVE TO LET A LOT GO
EFFECTIVELY STOP PROSECUTING
PEOPLE BECAUSE THAT WILL MAKE US
SAFER.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO OUR VOTERS GET GUNS, YOURS
DON'T.
WE'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE.